our first presenter is beautiful
talented and Jewish apparently Mel
Gibson told me that he's obsessed
please welcome Scarlett Johansson you
know our next presenter from such films
as Hudson Hawk look who's talking
mercury rising color of night 5th
element hearts war please welcome them
Kutcher's dad Bruce Willis but as I say
I'm gonna be nice tonight I've changed
not as much as Bruce Jenner obviously
now Caitlyn Jenner
of course what a year she's had she
became a role model for trans people
everywhere showing great bravery in
breaking down barriers in destroying
stereotypes she didn't do a lot for
women drivers
no profanity that's fine
I've got a huge vocabulary no nudity see
that's a shame because I've got a huge
vocabulary but a tiny penis no that's
true doesn't matter I don't care it
works don't worry about it it's fine
it's fine
I don't know smut or innuendo and I'm
not to libel anyone and I mustn't
mention Mel Gibson this year not his
private life is politics
his recent films and especially not
Jodie Foster's beaver I haven't seen it
myself
I've spoken to a lot guys here they
haven't seen either but that doesn't
mean it's not any good
one Hollywood publication said that me
hosting would mean that some film stars
would stay away for fear of being made
fun of as it film stars a stay away from
the chance of winning a golden glow'
particular if their film company has
already paid for it joy and trainwreck
no not the names of Charlie Sheen's two
favorite hookers the films of our next
two presenters their best friends by the
way they wanted me to tell you that and
if you forget they said they they'd
tweet you and remarked basically they're
there come round and shout it through
their best friend it's like they've
never had a friend before please welcome
Amy Schumer and Jennifer Lawrence
talking of The Walking Dead
congratulations to Hugh Hefner who was
getting married at the age of 84 to 24
year old Beauty Crystal Harris and when
she was asked why she was marrying him
she said because he lied about his age
he told me it was 94 Oh
don't worry hold out and just just don't
look at it when you touch it
ask them
I love this next presenter
he's so-called he's the star of Iron Man
two girls and a guy Wonder Boys sorry
these porn films what Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang Bowfinger really yeah the Academy
come on
he has done all those films but many of
you in this room probably know him best
from such facilities as the Betty Ford
Clinic and Los Angeles County Jail
please welcome Robert Downey jr. it was
a big year for 3d movies Toy Story
Despicable Me Tron seems like everything
this year was 3-dimensional except the
characters in The Tourist I feel bad
about that joke all right no no I tell
you why I'm jumping on the bandwagon
because I haven't even seen the tourist
who has and but no it must be good
because it's nominated so shut up okay
and I'd like to quash this ridiculous
rumor going around that the only reason
the tourist was nominated was so the
Hollywood Foreign Press could hang out
with Johnny Depp and Angelina Jolie that
is that is rubbish that is not the only
reason they also accepted bribes let's
Jennifer Lawrence made the news when she
demanded equal pay for women in
Hollywood and she received yeah
overwhelming support from people
everywhere there were marches on the
street with nurses and factory workers
saying how the how can a 25 year old
live on 52 million this is but there
were plumbers around the world going
poor girl UN's over rocky now so but
joking aside of course women should be
that paid the same as men for doing the
same job and I'd like to say now that
I'm getting paid exactly the same as
Tina and Amy did last year but hopefully
now I know there was two of them but
it's not my fault if they want to share
the money is it listen if you do win
tonight remember that no one cares about
that award as much as you do okay
don't get emotional it's embarrassing
okay that award is no offense worthless
it's a bit of metal that some nice old
confused journalists wanted to give you
in person so they could meet you and
have a selfie with you okay that's all
it is right when Brad and Angelina see
our next two adorable little presenters
they're gonna want to adopt them please
welcome Kevin hi and Ken Jeong also not
nominated I love you Philip Morris
Jim Jim Carrey and Ewan McGregor to
heterosexual actors pretending to be gay
so the complete opposite of some famous
Scientologists then
probably I want to say somewhat nice
about now before he comes out so oh yeah
okay here you go I'd rather have a drink
with him in his hotel room tonight than
with Bill Cosby please Malcolm now
Gibson for any of you don't know the
Golden Globes are just like the Oscars
but without all that esteem the Golden
Globes are to the Oscars what Kim
Kardashian is to Kate Middleton
basically
well bit louder bit trashy bit drunker
and more easily bought alleged I've got
three I've got three golden roads myself
so I can set ones a doorstop one I used
to hit burglars with and when I keep by
the bed two doesn't matter why it's mine
it's time it's mine I won it fair and
square
it's just the right shape and size it's
nothing yeah so to be clear that was a
joke about me shoving golden globes that
I've won up my ass other celebrity
scandal Justin Bieber nearly had to take
a paternity test what a waste of a test
that would have been no he's not the
father the only way that he could have
impregnated a girl was if he'd borrowed
on a Martha Stewart's old turkey basters